toujours des tensions à minsk où de
nombreux biélorusse continue de demander
la démission d'alexandre loukachenko
vous allez le voir sur ces images des
manifestants arrêtés mais aussi les
journalistes qui s'apprêtait à couvrir
un rassemblement hier dans la capitale
une vingtaine d'entre eux fuient sud
reuters le spoutnik pour encore et
hippies ont été conduits dans un
commissariat pour un contrôle d'identité
des rassemblements contre la réélection
du président sortant au lieu dans le
centre de minsk place de l'indépendance
une contre manifestation était organisée
toujours à minsk cette fois ci en
soutien à alexandre loukachenko